[Music]
welcome to the future of life institute
podcast i'm lucas perry
recently we had a conversation between
max tegmark and yaval noah harari
where in consideration of 21st century
technological issues you've all
recommended
quote get to know yourself better it's
maybe the most
important thing in life we haven't
really progressed much in the
last thousands of years and the reason
is that yes
we keep getting this advice but we don't
really want to do it
i mean especially as technology will
give us all
at least some of us more and more power
the temptations of naive utopias are
going to be more and more
irresistible and i think the really most
powerful check on these naive utopias is
really getting to know yourself better
unquote drawing inspiration from this
our following podcast was with andres
gomez emilson
and david pierce on different views of
identity
like open closed and empty individualism
and their importance in the world our
conversation today with
anthony aguirre follows up on and
further explores the importance of
questions of self and identity in the
21st century
this episode focuses on exploring this
question from a physics perspective
where we discuss the view of reality
as fundamentally consisting of
information
this helps us to ground what actually
exists how we come to know that
and how this challenges our commonly
held intuitions about their existing
a singular concrete reality out there
populated by conventionally accepted
objects and things like
cups and people that we often take for
granted without much
challenging or looking into much
this conversation subverted many of my
assumptions about
science and physics and the nature of
reality
and if something like that sounds
interesting or
appealing to you then i think you'll
find this conversation valuable as well
for those of you not familiar with
anthony anthony is
a physicist that studies the formation
nature and evolution of the universe
focusing primarily on the
model of eternal inflation the idea
that inflation goes on forever in some
regions of the universe
and what it may mean for the ultimate
beginning of the universe and time
he is the co-founder and associate
scientific director
of the foundational questions institute
and is also a co-founder of the future
of life institute
he also co-founded metaculous an effort
to
optimally aggregate predictions about
scientific discoveries
technological breakthroughs and other
interesting issues
the future of life institute is a
non-profit and this podcast is funded
and supported by listeners like you
so if you find what we do on this
podcast to be important and beneficial
please consider supporting the podcast
by donating at futureoflife.org
donate these contributions make it
possible for us to bring you
conversations like these and to develop
the podcast further
you can also follow us on your preferred
listening platform by searching for us
directly and following the links on the
page for this podcast found in the
description
and with that let's get into our
conversation with anthony aguirre
so the last time we had you on we had a
conversation on information could you
take us through the history
of how people have viewed fundamental
reality and fundamental ontology over
time
from a kind of idealism to them
materialism
to them this new shift that's informed
by quantum mechanics about
seeing things as being constituted of
information
so without being a historian of science
i can only give you the general
impression
that i have and of course through
history many different people have
viewed things very different ways
so i would say in the history of
humanity there have obviously been many
many ways to think about the ultimate
nature of reality if you will
starting with a sense that the
fundamental nature of
external reality is one that's based on
different substances
and tendencies and some level of
regularity in those things but without a
sense that there are
firm or certainly not mathematical
regularities and things
and that there are causes of events but
without a sense that those
causes can be described in some
mathematical way
so that changed obviously in terms of
western science with the advent of
mechanics by galileo and newton and
others showing
that there are not just regularities in
the sense that the same result will
happen from the same causes over and
over again that was appreciated for a
long time
but that those could be accessed not
just experimentally but
modeled mathematically and that there
could be
a relatively small set of mathematical
laws
that could then be used to explain a
very wide range of different physical
phenomena
i think that sense was not there before
it was clear that things caused
other things and events caused other
events but i suspect the thinking was
that it was more in a
one-off way like that's a complicated
thing it's caused by a whole bunch of
other complicated things
in principle those things are connected
but there wasn't a sense that
you could get in there and understand
what that connection was
analytically or intellectually and
certainly not in a way
that had some dramatic economy in the
sense that we now appreciate from
galileo and newton and subsequent
physics
once we had that change to mathematical
laws then there was a question of what
are those mathematical laws describing
and the answer there was essentially
that those mathematical laws are
describing
particles and forces between particles
and at some level a couple of other
auxiliary things like space and time
are sort of there in the backdrop but
essentially the nature of reality is a
bunch of little bits of stuff
that are moving around under
mathematically specified forces
that is a sort of complete ish
description i mean certainly
newton would have and have not said that
that's a complete description in the
sense that
newton's view there were particles and
those particles made up things
and the forces told them exactly what to
do but at the same time there were lots
of other things in newton's
conception of reality like god and
presumably other entities
so it's not exactly clear how
materialist newton or galileo
for example were but as time went on
that became a more
entrenched idea among hardcore
theoretical physicists at least our
physicists
that there was ultimately this truest
most fundamental most base description
of reality that was
lots of particles moving around under
mathematical forces
now that i think is a conception that is
very much still with us in many senses
but has
taken on a much deeper level of subtlety
given the advent of
modern physics including particularly
quantum mechanics
and also i think a sort of modern
recognition
or sort of higher level maybe of
sophistication and thinking about the
relation between different descriptions
of natural phenomena so let's talk about
quantum mechanics first
quantum mechanics does say that there
are particles in a sense like you can
say that there are particles
but particles aren't really the thing
you can ask questions of reality that
sort of entail
that reality is made of particles and
you will get answers
that look like answers about particles
but you can also ask
questions about the same physical system
about how it is as a wave and you will
get answers about how it is as a wave
and in general in quantum mechanics
there are all sorts of questions that
you can ask and
you will get answers about the physical
system in the terms that you ask those
questions about
so as long as it is a sort of
well-defined physical experiment that
you can do
and you can translate into a kind of
mathematical form what does it mean to
do that experiment
quantum mechanics gives you a way to
compute
predictions for how that experiment will
turn out
without really taking a particular view
on
what that physical system is like is it
a particle or is it a wave or is it
something else
and i think this is important to note
it's not just that quantum mechanics
says that things are particles and waves
at the same time
it's that there are all sorts of things
at the same time
so you can ask how much of my phone is
an
elephant in quantum mechanics like a
phone is totally not the same thing as
an elephant
but a phone has a wave function so if i
knew the wave function of the phone
and i knew a procedure for asking is
something an elephant then i could apply
that procedure
to the phone and the answer would not be
no the phone is definitely not an
elephant
the answer would be the phone is a tiny
tiny tiny tiny tiny bit
an elephant okay so this is very
exaggerated because we're talking like
phones and elephants all these numbers
are so tiny but the point is that i can
interrogate reality and quantum
mechanics in many different ways like i
can formulate whatever
questions i want and it will give me
answers in terms of those questions and
generally
if my questions totally mismatch with
what the system is i'll get no it's not
really that but the no
is always a no the probability is
incredibly tiny that it's that
but in quantum mechanics there's always
some chance that if you look at your
phone
you'll notice that it's an elephant it's
just that that number is so tiny that it
never matters but when you're talking
about individual particles
you might find that that probability is
significant that the particle is
somewhat different than you thought it
was
and that's part of the quantum
uncertainty and weirdness
can you unpack a little bit that quantum
uncertainty and weirdness that explains
when you ask questions to quantum
mechanics you don't ever
get definite answers is that right
almost never
so there are occasions where you get
definite answers if you
ask a question of a quantum system and
it gives you an answer and then you ask
that question immediately again
you'll get the same answer for sure what
does immediately mean
really immediately so so formally like
immediately immediately
if time goes by between the two
measurements and the system can evolve a
little bit and then you won't definitely
get the same answer
that is if you have a quantum system
there is a particular set
of questions that you can ask it that
you will get definite answers to
and the quantum state essentially is
that set of questions
like when you say an electron is here
and it has this spin that is it's
rotating around this direction
what you really mean is that there are a
particular set of questions
like where are you and what is your spin
that if you ask them of this electron
you would get a definite answer
now if you take that same electron that
i was going to ask those questions to
and i would get a definite answer
because that's the state the electron is
in
but you come along and ask a different
question than one of the ones that is in
that list
you will get an answer but it won't be a
definite answer so that's kind of the
fundamental hallmark of quantum
mechanics is that
the list of questions you can ask to
which you will get a definite answer
is a finite one and for a little
particle is like a very short list like
an electron it's a very short list
is this because the act of observation
includes
interaction with the particle in such a
way that it is changed
by the interaction i think that's a
useful way to look at it in a sense
but it's slightly misleading in the
sense that as i said if you ask exactly
the right question
then you will get a definite answer so
you haven't interfered with the system
at all if you ask exactly the right
question
that means performing the kind of
experiment that doesn't
change what the particle will be doing
or its nature is that what that means
yes it's sort of like you've got a very
very particularly shaped net
and you can cast it on something and if
the thing happens to have exactly the
right shape your net just falls right
over it and it doesn't affect the thing
at all and you say oh it has that
property
but if it has any other shape then your
net kind of messes it up
it gets perturbed and you catch
something in your net then that is your
experiment
but you mess up the system while you're
doing it but it's not that you
necessarily mess up the system
it's that you're asking it a question
that it isn't ready to answer
definitively
but rather some other question so this
is always true but it's kind of the
crucial thing
of reality but the crucial thing about
quantum mechanics is that that list is
finite
we're used to asking any question that i
i've got a mug you know
i can ask is it brown is it here is it
there is
you know how heavy is it whatever
question i think of i feel like i can
answer
i can ask the question and there will be
an answer to it because
whatever question i ask if it's a
well-defined question before i ask it
the mug either has that property or
doesn't
but quantum mechanics tells us that is
true but there's only a finite number of
answers that are built into the object
and i can ask other questions
but i just can't expect the answer to
already be there in the sense that i'll
get a definite answer to it
so this is a very subtle way that
there's this interactive process between
the observer and the thing that's
observed if we're talking about
something that is maximally
specified that it has a particular
quantum state there is some way that it
is in a sense
but you can't ever find that out because
as soon as you start asking questions of
it you change the thing
unless you happen to ask exactly the
right questions
but in order to ask exactly the right
questions you would already have to know
what state it's in
and the only way you can do that is by
actually creating the system
effectively so if i create an electron
in a particular state
in my lab then i know what state it's in
and i know exactly what questions to ask
it in order to get answers that are
certain but if i just come across an
electron in the wild
i don't know exactly what questions to
ask and so i just have to ask whatever
questions i will and chances are
it won't be the right questions for that
electron and i won't ever know whether
they were or not because i'll just get
some set of answers
and i won't know whether those were the
properties that the electron actually
had
already or if they were the ones that it
fell into by chance
upon my asking those questions how much
of this
is actual properties and features about
the particles in and of themselves and
how much is it
about the fact that we're like observers
or agents that have to
interact with the particles in some ways
in order to get information about them
such that we can't ask too many
questions without perturbing the thing
in and of itself and then not being able
to get definitive answers to other
questions
well i'm not sure how to answer that
because i think it's just that is the
structure of
quantum mechanics which is the structure
of reality so it's explicitly
posed in terms of quantum states of
things
and a structure of observations that can
be made or observables that can be
measured so you can see whether the
system has a particular value of that
observable or not
you know if you take out the observation
part or the measurement part
you just have a quantum state which
evolves according to some equation
and that's fine but that's not something
you can actually compare in any sense to
reality or to observation or use in any
way
you need something that will connect
that quantum state and
evolution equation to something that you
can actually
do or observe and that i think that is
something that's a little bit different
you know you can
say in newtonian mechanics or classical
physics there's something
arguably reasonable about saying here is
the system it's these particles and
they're moving around
in this way and that's saying something
now i think you can argue about whether
that's actually true that that's saying
something
but you can talk about the particles
themselves in a fairly meaningful way
without talking about the
observer or the person who's measuring
it or something like that whereas in
quantum mechanics it's really fairly
useless to talk about the wave function
of something without talking about
the way that you measure things or the
basis that you operated on and so on
now with a long sort of digression but i
think that's crucial because
that i think is a major underlying
change in the way that we think about
reality
not as something that is purely out
there
but understanding that even to the
extent that there's something out there
any sense of our experiencing that is
unavoidably
an interactive one in a way that you
cannot ignore
the interaction that you might have this
idea that there's an external
objective reality that although it's
inconvenient and
although on an everyday basis you might
mess with it a little bit when you
interact with it in principle
it's out there and if you could just be
careful enough you could avoid that
input from the observer quantum
mechanics says no that's a fundamental
part of it there's no avoiding that it's
a basic part of the theory
that reality is made up of this
combination of the measure
and the state i also think that
once you admit because you have to in
this case that there is
more to a useful or complete
description of reality than just the
kind of objective
state of the physical system then you
notice that there are a bunch of other
things that
actually are there as well that you have
to admit are part of reality
so if you ask some quantum mechanical
question like if i ask
is my mug brown and is it spinning
where is it those kinds of questions you
have to ask what is the
reality status of those questions or
like the categories that i'm defining
and asking those questions
like brownness what is that that's
obviously something that
i invented not me personally but i
invented in this particular case
brownness is something that biological
creatures and humans and so on invented
the sensation of brown is something that
biological creatures may be
devised the calling something brown and
the word brown or obviously
human and english creations so those are
things that are
created through this process and are not
there
certainly in the quantum state and yet
if we say
that the quantum state on its own is not
a
meaningful or useful description of
reality but we have to augment it with
the sorts of questions that we ask and
the sort of procedure of asking and
getting
questions answered then those extra
things that we have to put into
description
entail a whole lot of different things
so there's not just the wave function
so in that simple example there's a set
of questions
and possible answers to those questions
that the mug could give me
and there are different ways of talking
about how mathematically to define those
questions
one way is to call them coarse grained
states or macro states
that is there are lots of ways that
reality can be but i want to
extract out certain features of reality
so if i take the
set of possible ways that a mug can be
there's like some tiny subset of all
those different ways that the atoms in
my mug could be that i would actually
call a mug
and a smaller subset of those that i
would call a brown mug and a smaller
subset of those and i would call a brown
mug that's sitting still
and so on so they're kind of subsets of
the set of all possible ways that a
physical system with that many atoms and
that mass and so on could be
and when i'm asking questions about the
mug like are you brown
i'm asking is the system in that
particular subset
of possibilities that i call a brown mug
sitting on a table
i would say that at some level almost
all of what we do
in interacting with reality is like that
process there's this huge
set of possible realities that we could
inhabit
what we do are to divvy up that reality
to many many possibilities
corresponding to questions that we might
ask and answers to those questions we
might ask
and then we go and ask those questions
of reality and we get sort of yes or no
answers to them
and quantum mechanics is sort of the
enactment of that process
with full exactness that applies to even
the smaller systems
but we can think of that process just on
a day-to-day level like we can think of
what are all the possible ways that the
system could be
and then ask certain questions is it
this is it that
so this is a conception of reality
that's kind of like a big game of 20
questions
every time we look out at reality we're
just asking different questions of it
and we're narrowing down the possibility
space of how reality is by asking those
questions getting answers to it
to me a really interesting question is
like what is the ontological
reality status of all those big sets of
questions that we're asking
your tendency as a theoretical physicist
is to say oh the wave function is the
thing that's
real and that's what actually exists and
all these extra things are just extra
things that we made up and are glopped
onto the wave function
but i think that's kind of a very
impoverished view of reality
not just impoverished but completely
useless and empty of any utility or
meaning
because quantum mechanics by its nature
requires
both parts the questions and the state
if you cut out all the questions you're
just left with this very
empty thing that has no applicability or
meaning
but doesn't that tell us how reality is
in and of itself
i don't think it tells you anything
honestly it's almost impossible to even
say
what the wave function is except in some
terms
like if i just write down like okay the
wave function of the universe is
psi what did that tell me nothing
there's nothing there there's no way
that i could even communicate to you
what the wave function
is without reference to some
set of questions because remember the
wave function is a definite set of
answers to a particular set of questions
so
i have to communicate to you the set of
questions to which
the wave function is the definite answer
and those questions are things that have
to do with macroscopic reality
there's no way that i can tell you what
the wave function is
if i were to try to communicate it to
you without reference to those questions
like if i say okay i've got a thingy
here
and it's got a wave function and you ask
me okay what is the wave function
i don't know how to tell you i could
tell you it's mass but now
what i'm really saying is here's a set
of energy measuring
things that i might do and the
amplitude for getting those different
possible outcomes and that energy
measuring thing is
you know point one for that one and
point two for that one and so on
but i have to tell you what those energy
measuring things are in order to be able
to tell you what the wave function is
if you like go back to the starting
conditions of the universe that initial
state is
a definite thing right prior to any
observers and defined
coherently and exactly in and of itself
right
i don't know if i would say that i
understand that for us to know anything
we have to ask questions
i'm asking about something that i know
has no utility because
we're always gonna be the observer
standing in reference
right but just to think about reality in
and of itself
right but you're assuming that there is
such a thing and it's not entirely clear
to me so i recognize that there's a
desire to feel like there is a sort of
objective reality that is out there and
that there's meaning to saying what that
reality is
but that is not entirely clear to me
that that's a safe assumption to make
okay so it is true that we can go back
in time and attribute all kinds of
pretty objective properties of the
universe and it certainly is true that
it can't be that we needed
people and observers and things back at
the beginning in order to be able to
talk about those things
but it's a very thorny question to me
that it's meaningful to say that there
was
a quantum state that the universe had at
the very beginning
when i don't know what operationally
that means like i wouldn't know how to
describe that quantum state or make it
meaningful other than
in terms of measurable things which
require adding a whole bunch of
ingredients
to the description of what the universe
is
to say that the universe started in this
quantum state
to make that meaningful requires these
extra ingredients
but we also recognize that those extra
ingredients are
themselves parts of the universe so
either you have to take this view that
there is a quantum state and somehow
we're going to get out of that in in
this kind of circular
self-consistent way a bunch of measuring
apparatuses
that are hidden in that quantum state
and make certain measurements
and then define the quantum state in
this bootstrapping way
or you have to say that the quantum
state and i'm not sure how different
these things are that the quantum state
is part of
reality but in order to actually specify
what reality is
there's a whole bunch of extra
ingredients that we have to define
and we have to sort of put in there and
that's kind of the view that i take
nowadays
that there is reality and then there's
our description of reality and as we
describe reality
one of the things that we need to
describe reality are quantum states and
one of the things that we need to
describe reality are
coarse grainings or systems of
measurement or bases
and so on there are all these extra
things we need to put in and the quantum
states are one of them and a very
important one and
evolution equations are one of them in a
very important one but
to identify reality with the state
plus the fundamental laws that evolve
that state i just don't think is quite
the right way to think about it
okay so this is all very illuminating
for this perspective here that we're
trying to
explore which is the universe being
simply constituted
of information yeah so let's talk about
that
once you let go i think of the idea that
there's matter
that is made of particles and then there
are arrangements of that matter
and there are things that that matter
does but the matter is kind of this
intrinsically existing stuff
once you start to think of there being a
state
which is a set of answers to questions
that set of answers to questions is a
very informative thing
it's like a kind of maxillary
informative thing but it isn't a
different
kind of thing to other sets of answers
to questions
that is to say that i've got information
about something
kind of is saying that i've asked a
bunch of questions and i've gotten
answers
about it so i know about it if i keep
asking
enough incredibly detailed questions
that maybe i've
maximally specified the state of the cup
and i have as much information as i can
have about the cup
but in that process as i ask more and
more information as i more and more
specify what the cup is like
there's no particular place in which the
cup changes its nature
so i start out asking questions and i
get more and more and more information
until i get the most information that i
can
and then i call that that's the most
information i can get and now i've
specified the quantum state of the cup
but in that sense then a quantum state
is like the sort of end state of a
process
of interrogating a physical system to
get more and more information about it
so to me that suggests this
interpretation that the nature of
something like the quantum state of
something
is an informational thing it's
identified with a maximal set of
information
that you can have about something but
that's kind of one end of the spectrum
the maximal knowing about that thing end
of the spectrum
but if we don't go that far then we just
have less information about the thing
and once you start to think that way
well what then isn't information
if the nature of things is to be a state
and a set of questions and the state
gives me answers to those questions
that's a set of information but as i
said that sort of applies to all
physical systems that's kind of
what they are according to quantum
mechanics
so there used to be a sense i think that
there was a thing
it was a bunch of particles and then
when i asked questions
i could learn about that thing the
lesson to me of quantum mechanics is
that
there's no space between
the answers to questions that i get when
i ask questions of a thing
and the thing itself the thing is
in a sense the set of answers to the
questions
that i have or could ask of it
it becomes much less of a kind of
physical tangible thing made of stuff
and much more of a thing made out of
information and it's information that i
can get by interacting with that thing
but there isn't a thing there that the
information is about
that notion seems to be sort of absent
there's no need to think that there is a
thing that the information is about all
we know is the information
is that true of the particles arranged
cup wise or the cup thing that is there
is it true of that thing and of itself
or is that basically just the truth of
being an epistemic agent who's trying to
interrogate the cup thing
suppose the fundamental nature of
reality was a bunch of particles
then what i said is still true i can
imagine if things like observers
exist then they can ask questions and
they can get answers
and those will be answers about the
physical system that kind of has this
intrinsic nature of bits of stuff
and it would still i think be true that
most of reality is made of
everything but the little bits of stuff
the little bits of stuff are only there
at the very end like if you ask the very
most precise questions you get more and
more
sense of oh there are little bits of
stuff but i think what's interesting is
that what quantum mechanics tells us is
we keep
getting more and more fine-grained
information about something
but then at the very end rather than
little bits of stuff it sort of
disappears before our eyes like there
aren't any little bits of stuff there
there's just the answers to the most
refined sets of questions that we can
ask
so that's where i think there's sort of
a difference is that there's this sense
in classical physics that
underlying all these questions and
answers and information
is this other thing of a different
nature that
is matter and as it has a different
fundamental quality to it than the
information
and in quantum mechanics it seems to me
like there's no
need to think that there is such a thing
but there is no need to think that there
is
some other different stuff that is
non-informational that's out there that
the information is about
because the informational description is
complete
so i guess there's two questions here
that come out of this it would be good
if you could
define and unpack what information
exactly is
and then if you could explore and get
further into the idea
of how this challenges our notion of
what a macroscopic thing is or what a
microscopic or what a quantum
thing is something that we believe to
have identity
and then also how this impacts identity
like cup identity or like particle
identity
what it means for people and galaxies
and
the universe to be constituted of
information so those two things
okay so there are lots of ways to talk
about information there are also
qualitative and quantitative ways to
talk about it so let me talk about the
quantitative way first
so you can say that if i have a whole
possibility space like many
different possibilities for the way
something can be
and then i restrict those possibilities
to a smaller set of possibilities in
some way either i say it's definitely in
one of these or
maybe there's a higher probability that
it's one of these than one of those like
in some way restrict rather than every
possibility is the same
i say that some possibilities are more
than others they're more likely or it's
restricted to some subset
then i have information about that
system and that information is precisely
the gap between
everything being just equally likely and
every possibility being
equally good and knowing that some of
them are more
likely or valid or something than others
so information is that gap
that says it's more this than
some of those other things okay so
that's a super general way of talking
about it but that can be made very
mathematically precise
so if i say there are four bits of
information
stored in my computer exactly what i
mean is that
there are a bunch of registers and if i
don't know whether they're
ones or zeros i say i know have no
information
if i know that these four are one one
zero one
then i've restricted my full set of
possibilities to this
subset in which those are one one zero
one
and i have those four bits of
information so i can be very
mathematically precise about this
and i can even say if the first bit well
i don't know whether it's 0 1 but it's
75
chance that it's 0 and 25 chance that
it's one that's still information
it's less than one bit of information
people think of
bits as being very discreet things but
you can have fractions of bits of
information
there's nothing wrong with that the very
general definition as
restrictions away from every possibility
being equally likely
to some being more likely than others
and that can be made mathematically
precise and is exactly the sort of
information we talk about when we say my
hard drive is 80 gigabytes in size or i
have 20 megabits per second of internet
speed
it's exactly that sort of information
that we're quantifying
now when i think about a cup
i can think about the system in some way
like there are
some number of atoms like 10 to the 25th
or whatever atoms
or electrons and protons and neutrons or
whatever and
they're then some huge huge possible set
of ways that those things can be
and some tiny tiny tiny tiny tiny tiny
almost infinitesimally tiny subset of
those ways that can be
are something that i would label a cup
so if i say oh look i have a cup
i'm actually specifying a vast amount of
information by saying
look i have a cup now if i say look i
have a cup
and inside it is some dregs of coffee
i've got a huge amount more information
now it doesn't feel like a huge amount
more of information
it's just like yeah what did i expect
drugs of coffee it's not that big of a
deal but
physically speaking it's a huge amount
of information that i've specified just
by noticing
that there are dregs of coffee instead
in the cup instead of drugs of
all kinds of other liquids and all kinds
of other states and so on
so that's the quantitative aspect i can
quantify
how much information is in a description
of a system
and the description of is important
because you might come along and you
can't see this cup
so i can tell you there's some stuff on
my desk you know a lot less about what's
on my desk than i do
so we have different descriptions of
this same system and i've got a whole
lot more information than you do about
what's on my desk
so the information is and this is an
important thing is
associated with somebody's description
of the system
not necessarily a person's but any way
of specifying probabilities of the
system being
in a subset of all its of its
possibilities whether that's a somebody
describing it or whatever else anything
that defines probabilities
over the states that the system could be
in that's defining an amount of
information
associated with those probabilities
so there's that quantity but there's
also when i say
what is a mug so you can say that the
mug is
made of protons electrons and neutrons
but of course pretty much anything in
our world is made of protons neutrons
and electrons
so what makes this a mug rather than a
phone
or a little bit of an elephant or
whatever is the particular arrangement
that those atoms have to say that a mug
is
just protons neutrons and electrons i
think is totally misleading in the sense
that the protons neutrons and electrons
are the least informative part of what
makes it a mug
so there's a quantity associated with
that the mug part of possibility space
is very small compared to
all of the possibilities so that means
that there's a lot of information in
saying that it's a mug
but there's also the quality of what
that particular subset is
and that that particular subset is
connected in various ways
with things in my description like
solidity and
mass and brownness and hardness
and hollowness it is at the intersection
of a whole bunch of other
properties that a system might have so
each of those properties i can also
think of as subsets of possibility space
suppose i take all things that are a
kilogram that's how many protons
neutrons and electrons they have
so that's my system there's a gazillion
different ways that a kilogram of
protons neutrons and electrons can be
or we could write down the very
exponential numbers that it is
now if i then say okay let me take a
subset of
of that possibility space that are solid
that's a very small
subset there are lots of ways things can
be gases and liquids okay so i made a
small subset
now let me take another property which
is hardness so that's another subset
of all possibilities and where hardness
intersects solid i have hard solid
things
and so on so i can keep adding
properties on and when i've specified
enough properties
it's something that i would give the
label of a mug so when i ask
what is a mug made of in some sense it's
made of protons and chosen electrons but
i think in a more meaningful sense it's
made of the properties
that make up it being a mug rather than
some other thing
and those properties are these
subsets or these ways of breaking up the
state space of the mug into different
possibilities
in that sense i kind of think of the mug
as more made of
properties with an associated amount of
information with them
and the sort of fundamental nature of
the mug is that set of properties
and your reaction to that might be like
yes it has those properties but it is
made of stuff but then if you go back
and ask what is that stuff
again the stuff is a particular set of
properties
as deep as you go these properties all
the way down until you get to the
properties of electrons protons and
neutrons which are just
particular ways that those are and
answers to those questions that you get
by asking the right questions of those
things
and so that's what it means to me to
take the view that everything is made up
of
information in some way is it's to take
a view that there isn't a separation
between
the properties that we intersect to say
that it is something
and the thing itself that has those
properties
so in terms of like identity here there
is a question
about the identity status of the cup i
think that from hearing your
talks previously you proposed a spectrum
of subjectivity and objectivity rather
than it being a kind of binary
thing because the cup is a set of
questions and properties
can you expand a little bit about the
identity of the cup
and what the meaning of the cup given
that it is constituted from this quantum
mechanical perspective of just
information about the kinds of questions
and properties we may ask
of coupling objects i think there are
different ways in which the description
of a system or
what it is that we mean when we say it
is this kind of thing
it is a cup or the laws of physics
or like there is this theorem of
mathematics
or i feel itchy are three fairly
different statements
but my view is that we should not try to
sort them into
objective facts of the world and
individual subjective
or personal perspective kind of things
but there's really this continuum in
between them
so when i say that there's this thing on
my desk that is a cup
there's my particular point of view that
sees the cup
and has a whole bunch of personal
associations with the cup like i really
like this one
i like that it's made out of clay i've
had a lot of nice coffee out of it and
so like
so that's very personal stuff there's
cupnus
which is obviously not there in the
fires of the big bang
which is something that has evolved
socially and via biological utility
and all the processes that have led to
our technological society and our
culture having things that we store
stuff in and liquids and
that cupness though is kind of like the
platonic idealism that we experience
imbued upon the object right
because of our conventional experience
of reality we can forget that the
cupness experience is there like that
and we
identify it and like reify it right
and then we're like oh there's just
cupness there we get this sense that
there's an objectively speaking cup
out there but we forget the level of
creation and formulation that has gone
on
historically and socially and so on to
create this notion this
shared collective notion of cupness that
is a creation
of humanity and that we all carry around
with us as part of our
mental apparatus and we say oh cupness
is an objective thing and we all agree
that this is a cup and the cup is out
there
but really it's not it's somewhere in
this spectrum
in the sense that there will certainly
be cups that it's ambiguous whether it's
a cup or not
there will be people who don't know what
a cup is and so on
it's not like every possible person will
agree even whether this is a brown cup
some people may say
well actually i'd call that grayish
it feels fairly objective but obviously
there's
this intersubjective component to it of
all these ingredients that we invented
going into making that a cup now there
are other things that feel
more objective than that in a sense like
the laws of physics or
some things about mathematics where you
say like oh the ratio of the
circumference to the diameter of a
circle
we didn't make that up that was there at
the beginning of the universe
and that's a longer conversation but
certainly that feels
more objective than the cup once it's
understood
what the terms are there's sort of no
disagreeing with that statement
as long as we're in flat space and so on
and there's no
sense in which we feel like that
statement has a large human
input we certainly feel like that ratio
was what it was
and then we can express it as this
series of fractions and so on
long before there were people that was
true so there's a feeling that that is a
much more
objective thing and i think that's fair
to say it has
more of that objectivity than a cup
but what i disagree with and find kind
of
not useful is the notion that there's a
demarcation
between things that are and aren't
objective
i sort of feel like you will never find
that bright line between
an actually objective thing and a not
actually objective thing
it will always be somewhere on this
continuum and it's probably not even a
one-dimensional continuum but somewhere
in this
spectrum between things that are quite
objective and things that are very very
subjective
will be somewhere in that region kind of
everything that makes up our world that
we experience
right so i guess you could just kind of
boil that down by saying
that is true because all of the things
are just constituted of the kinds of
properties and questions that you're
interested in asking
about the thing and the questions about
the mathematical properties
feel and seem more objective because
they're derived from primitive
self-intuitive axioms and then
it's just question wormholes from there
you know that stand upon bedrock
of slightly more and more dubious and
relativistic
and subjective questions and properties
that one may or may not be interested in
yeah so there are a couple things i
would say to that one is that there's a
tendency among some people to feel like
more objective is
more true or more real or something like
that whereas i think it's
different and with more true and more
real
tends to come a normative sense of
better like more true things are
better things there are two steps there
from
more objective to more true and for more
true
to better both of which are kind of ones
that we know
we shouldn't necessarily just swallow
because i think it's more complicated
than that
so more objective is different and might
be more useful for certain purposes like
it's really
great that the laws of physics are in
the very objective
side of the spectrum in that we feel
like once we've
found some lots of different people can
use them for all kinds of different
things without having to re-figure them
out and we can kind of agree on them
and we can also feel like they were true
a long time ago and use them for all
kinds of things that happened long ago
and far away so there are all these
great things about the fact that they
are
on this sort of objective side of things
at the same time the things that
actually matter to us and it are
like the most important things in the
world to us are totally subjective thing
love and human rights and the fact that
other humans exist right like all value
at some level
i certainly see value is very connected
with the subjective experience of
things that are experiencing things and
that's purely subjective
nobody would say that the subjective
experience of beings
is unimportant i think
so this was just to say that it's not
that objective is
better or more valuable or something
like that it's just different
and important in different ways the laws
of physics are super important and
useful in certain ways
but if someone only knew and applied the
laws of physics and held no regard or
importance for the
subjective experience of beings i would
be very worried about the sorts of
things that they would do
i think there's some way in which people
think dismissively of
things that are less objective or that
are subjective like oh that's just a
subjective
feeling of something or that's not like
the true objective reality like i'm
superior because i'm talking about the
true objective reality
and i just don't think that's a useful
way to think about it
yeah these deflationary memes or jokes
or arguments that
love is an absurd reduction of a bunch
of chemicals or whatever
that's this kind of reduction of the
supposed value of something which is
subjective but all of the things that we
care about most in life
we talked about this last time that like
hold together the fabric of reality and
provide a ton of meaning or subjective
things
what are these kinds of things i guess
from the perspective of this
conversation it's like
there are the kinds of questions that
you can ask about systems and like how
they will
interact with each other and the kinds
of properties that they have right
why are these particular questions and
properties important
well i mean historically and
evolutionarily speaking they have
particular functions right
so it seems clear and that i would agree
with you that there's the space of all
possible questions and properties we can
ask about things
and because of historical reasons we
care about a particularly arbitrary
subset of those questions and properties
that have functional
use and that is constituted of all these
subjective things like
cups and houses and like love and like
marriage and like rights
i'm only i think objecting to the notion
that those are
somehow less real or sort of derivative
of a description in terms of
particles or fields or mathematics
so the sense in which they're less real
is the sense in which we get confused
by the cupness being like a thing in the
world so that's why i wanted to
highlight that phenomenological sense of
cupnus before where the platonic
idealism we see of the cupness is there
in and of itself
yeah i think i agree with that so what
is it that defines whether or not
something falls
more on the objective side or more on
the subjective side
aren't all the questions that we ask
about macroscopic and fuzzy concepts
like love and human rights and cups and
houses and human beings
don't all those questions have
definitive answers as long as the
categories are coherent and properly
defined
i guess the way i see it is that there's
kind of a sense of how
broadly shared through agents and
through space and time
are those categorizations or those sets
of properties
cupness is pretty widespread but doesn't
go
further back in time than humanity
protozoa don't use cups
so cupness is fairly objective in that
sense
it's tricky because there's this
subjectivity object of the axis of how
widely
shared are the sets of properties and
then there's a different subject of
objective
axis of experience of my individual
phenomenological experience of
subjectivity
versus an objective view of the world
and i think those are connected but
they're not quite the same sense of
subjective and objective i think that to
put it on that axis
is actually a little bit confusing i
understand that the more functional that
a meme or
idea or concept is the more widely
shared it's going to be
but i don't think that just because more
and more agents are agreeing to use some
kind of concept like money
that that is becoming more objective i
think it's just becoming more shared
yeah that's fine i guess i would ask you
what does more and less objective
mean if it's not that yeah i mean i
don't know
um i'm not sure how to say something is
more or less objective without referring
to some
sense like that that it is more
widespread
in some way or that there are more sort
of
subjective views of the world that share
that set of descriptions
if we go back to the thinking about the
probabilities in whatever sense you're
defining the probabilities
and the properties the more perspectives
are using a shared set of
properties the more objectively defined
are the things that are defined by those
properties
now how to say that precisely like is
this objectivity level 12
because 12 people share that set of
properties and 50 people
share these so it's objectively level i
wouldn't want to quantify it that way
necessarily but i think there is some
sort of sense of that
that the more different perspectives on
the world
use that same set of descriptions in
order to interact with the world
the more kind of objective that set of
descriptions is
again i don't think that captures
everything like i still think
there was a sense in which the laws of
physics were objective before anyone was
talking about them and using them
that's quite difficult i mean when you
think about mathematics yeah i was going
to bring that up
you know if you think of mathematics as
you've got a set of axioms and a set of
rules for generating
true statements out of those axioms even
if you pick a particular set of rules
they're a huge number of sets of
possible axioms
and then each set of axioms if you just
grind those rules on those axioms will
produce
just an infinite number of true
statements but grinding axioms into true
statements is not doing mathematics
i would say so it is true that every
true mathematical statement should have
a sequence of steps that goes from
axioms to that true mathematical
statement but for every thing that we
read in a math textbook
there's an exponentially large number of
other consequences
of axioms that just nobody cares about
because they're totally uninteresting
yeah there's no utility to them so this
is again finding
spaces of mathematics that have utility
what makes certain ones more useful than
others
so it seems like you know e euler's
number is
a very special number it's useful for
all kinds of stuff obviously there are
a continuous infinity of other numbers
that are just as valid as that one
right but there's something very special
about that one because it shows up all
the time it's really useful for all
these different things so we've picked
out that particular number
as being special and i would say there's
a lot of information associated with
that pointing to e
and saying oh look this number we've
done something by that pointing
there's a whole bunch of information and
interesting stuff associated with
pointing out that that number is special
so that pointing was something that we
humans have done at some level
there wasn't the symbol e or the notion
of e or anything
like that before humans were around
nonetheless there's some sense in which
once we
find e and see how cool it is and how
useful it is
we say it was always true that e to the
i x was cosine of x plus i sine of x
like that was always true
even though we just proved it a couple
of centuries ago and so on how could
that have not been true
and it was always true but it wasn't
always true that we knew that it was
interesting
so it's kind of the interestingness and
the pointing to that particular theorem
as being
an interesting one out of all the
possible consequences that you could
grind out of a set of axioms
that's what was created by humanity now
why
the process by which we noticed that
that was an interesting thing much more
interesting than many other things
how much objectivity there is to that is
an interesting question
surely some other species that we
encountered almost surely they would
have
noticed that that was a particularly
interesting mathematical fact
like we did why that's a really hard
question to answer
so there is a subjective or
non-objective
part of it in that we as a species
develop that thing the
interestingness of it wasn't always
there we kind of created that
interestingness of it
but we probably noticed its
interestingness for some reason
and that reason seems to go above and
beyond
the sort of human processes that noticed
it so there's no easy
answer to this i think my layman's
easy answer would be just that it helps
you describe and make
the formalization and development of
mathematical fields right
sure but is that helpfulness a fact of
the world or a contingent thing that
we've noticed
as we've developed mathematics
how among all species that ever could be
imagined that exist
would almost all of them identify that
as being useful and interesting or would
only some of them
and other ones have a very different
concept of what's useful and interesting
that's really hard to know and is it
more or less objective in that sort of
sense i guess
part of my intuition here is just that
it has to do with the way that our
universe is constituted
calculus is useful for like modeling and
following velocities and accelerations
and objects
in newtonian physics so like this
calculus thing has utility because of
this
right but that which makes it useful
that feels like it's something more
objective
right like calculus is inheriting its
objectiveness from the objective nature
of the universe that makes calculus
useful
the objectiveness is born of its
relationship to
the real world yes but again what does
that mean
it's hard to put your finger at all on
what that thing
is that the real world has that makes
calculus useful for describing it
other than saying the real world is well
described by calculus
right it feels very circular to say that
okay so i'm thoroughly confused then
about subjectivity and objectivity so
this is good
i think we all have this intense desire
to
feel like we understand what's going on
we don't really understand
how reality works or is constituted
we can nonetheless learn more about how
it's constituted and
sitting on that razor's edge between
feeling pride and like yes we figured a
bunch of stuff out and we really can
predict the world and we can do
technology and all these things
all of which is true while also feeling
the humility
that when we really go into it reality
is fundamentally
very mysterious i think is right but
difficult my frustration is when i see
people purporting to fully understand
things like
oh i get it this is the way the world is
and taking a very dismissive attitude
toward
thinking the world is not the way that
they particularly see it
and that's not as uncommon an attitude
as as one would like
right that is a lot of people's tendency
because there's a great desire
and safety feeling like you understand
this is the way that the world is and if
only these poor benighted other souls
could see it the way i do they'd be
better off
that's hard because we genuinely do
understand much much much more about the
world than we ever did
so much so that there is a temptation to
feel like we really understand it
and i think at some level that that's
more the notion
that i feel like it's important to push
back against the notion that
we get it all like you know we more or
less understand how the world is and how
it works and how it fundamentally
operates
among some circles that's more the
hubristic danger of falling into that
than there is falling into the we don't
know anything
although there are other parts of
society where there's the other end too
that the anti-intellectual stance is
that like
my conception of reality is just as good
as yours that i just made up yesterday
and we're all equally good at
understanding what the world is really
like
also quite dangerous the core
draw way here for me is just this
essential confusion about
how to navigate this space of what it
means for something to be more
subjective and objective
and the perspective of analyzing it
through the kinds of questions and
properties we would ask or be interested
in
what you were just saying also had me
reflecting a lot on people whose
identity is extremely caught up in
nationalism or like a team sport
they would seem to be trivial questions
or properties you could ask
like where did you happen to be born
which city
do you particularly have fondness
towards
the identity of really being like an
american
or like really being a fan of the
patriots
people become just completely enthralled
and engrossed by that
your consciousness and ego just gets
obliterated
into identification with i am an
american patriot fan
and like there's just no perspective
there's no context
when one goes way too far towards the
objective
when one is mistaking the nature of
things yeah
there are all sorts of mistakes that we
all make
all the time and it's interesting to see
pathologies in all directions in terms
of how we think about
the world in our relation to it and
there there's certain cases where you
feel like
if we could just all take a little bit
more of an objective view of this
everyone would be so much better off and
kind of vice versa
it takes a lot of very difficult skill
to approach our complex world and
reality
in a way that we're thinking about it in
a useful way
in this wide variety of different
circumstances where sometimes it's more
useful to think about it
more objectively and sometimes more
subjectively or
along all sorts of other different axes
it's a real challenge
i mean that's part of what it is to be
human and to
engage in a worthy way with other people
and with the world and so on is to have
to understand
the more and less useful and skillful
ways and lenses through which to look at
those things
at one time almost everything we do is
in error
but you also have to be forgiven because
almost everything that you could do
would be an error in some way from some
standpoint
and sometimes thinking that the cup is
objectively real
is an error thinking that you made up
the cup and invented it all on your own
is also an error so like the cup is real
and
isn't real and is made up and isn't made
up any way you think about it is kind of
wrong
but it's also all kind of okay because
you can still pick up the cup and take a
drink
so it's very tricky it's a tricky
reality we reside in but that's
good i think if everything was
straightforward and obvious that would
be a boring world
if everything were straightforward and
obvious then i would
reprogram everyone to not find
straightforward and obvious things
boring and then we would not have this
requirement to be in a complicated
understandable world okay i think
there's a douglas adams
line that if you figure it all out then
immediately it all stops and starts
again in a more complicated way that
becomes more and more difficult
and of course this is something that's
happened many many times before
i don't know how useful it is now but is
talking about
emergence here is that something that's
useful you think
for talking about identity maybe
there's a question of identity of what
makes
something one thing rather than another
and then there's another question of
personal identity and sort of my
particular
perspective or view of the world like
what i identify as my awareness my
consciousness
my phenomenal experience of the world
and that identity and how it persists
through time
that identity and how it does or doesn't
connect with other ones like is it truly
its own island or should i take a more
expansive view of it
and is it something that persists over
time
is there a core thing that persists over
time or is it succession of
or loosely identified or tightly
identified with each other
i'm not sure whether all the stuff that
we've been talking about in terms of
properties and questions and answers and
states and things
applies to that but i'm not sure that it
doesn't either i think it does
wouldn't the self or like questions on
personal identity
be arbitrary questions in a very large
state that we would be interested in
asking particular questions about what
constitutes the person
like is there a self the self is like a
squishy fuzzy concept like love
does the self exist does love exist
where do they fall on the subjective
objective scale
well there are many different questions
we could think about but if i think of
my identity through time i could maybe
talk about
how similar some physical system is to
the physical system i
identify as me right now and i could say
i'm sort of identified through time with
the physical system that is really much
like me
and physics makes that easy because
physical systems are very stable
and this body kind of evolves slowly but
once you get to the really hard
questions like suppose i
duplicate this physical system in some
way is my identity
one of those or two of those and what
happens if you destroy the original one
and you know those are
genuinely confusing questions that i'm
not sure that the sort of
niceties of understanding emergence in
the properties and so on
i'm not sure how much it has to say
about it i'm not sure that it doesn't
but
having thought a lot about the earlier
identity questions i feel no less
confused
the way in which emergence is helpful or
interesting to me is the way in which
the levels of reality at which human
beings conceptualize which would be like
quantum mechanics and then atomic
science and then chemistry
and then biology and so on we imagine
them as being sort of stacked up on each
other
and if reductionism is attractive to one
you would think that all the top layers
super vein upon the nature of the very
bottom layer
quantum mechanics which is true to some
sense
and you would want to say that there is
fundamental brute identity facts
about the like very very very base layer
so you could say that there are such
things as irreducible quantum
atoms like maybe they reduce into other
things
but that's an open question for now and
if we are
confident about the identity of those
things there's at least
a starting place you know from which we
would have true answers about
identity does that make sense well
the sentences make sense but i just
largely don't agree with them
for all the reasons that we've talked
about i think there needs to be a
word that is the opposite of emergence
like distillation or something
because i think it's useful to think
both directions like i think it is
certainly useful to be able to think
about i have a whole bunch of particles
that do these things
and then i have another description of
them that glosses over say the
individual
actions of the particles but create some
very reliable regularity that i can call
a law like thermodynamics or like
some chemical laws and so on so i think
that is true
but it's also useful to think of the
other direction which
is we have complicated physical systems
and
by making very particular
simplifications
and carving away a lot of the complexity
we
create systems that are simple enough to
have very simple laws describe them
i would call that a sort of distillation
process which is one that we do
so we go through this process when we
encounter new phenomena we kind of
look for ways that we can cut away
lots of the complexity cut away a lot of
the properties try to
create a system that's simple enough to
describe in some mathematical way
using some simple attenuated set of
concepts
and so on and then often we take that
set and then we try to work our way back
up by using those laws and kind of
having things that emerge from
that lower level description but i think
both processes are quite important and
it's a little bit
intellectually dangerous to think of
what i'd call the distillation process
as a truth-finding process like i'm
finding these laws that were
all already there rather than i'm
finding some
regularities that are left when i remove
all this extra stuff
and then forget that you've removed all
the extra stuff and that when you go
back from the so-called more fundamental
description
to the emerge description that you're
secretly sticking a lot of that stuff
back in
without noticing that you're doing it so
that's sort of my point of view that
the notion that we can go from this
description in terms of particles and
fields and that we could derive
all these emerged layers from it i think
it's just not true in practice for sure
but also not really true in principle
there's there's stuff that we have to
add
to the system in order to describe those
other levels
that we sort of pretend that we're not
adding we say oh i'm just assuming this
extra little thing but really you're
adding
concepts and quantities and all kinds of
other apparatus to the thing that you
started with
does that actually describe reality then
or does that give you
an approximation the emergent levels
sure it just gives you answers to
different questions than the
particle and field level does but given
that the particle and field level stuff
is still
there doesn't that higher order thing
still have the capacity
for like strange quantum things to
happen and that would not be accounted
for
in the emergent level understanding and
therefore it would not always be true
if there was some like entanglement or
like quantum tunneling business
going on yeah i think there's more
latitude perhaps
the statistical laws and statistical
mechanics are statistical laws
they're totally exact but the things
that they make
are statistical descriptions of the
world
that are approximate in some ways so
it's like they're approximate but
they're approximate in a very very
well-defined way
i mean it's certainly true that the
different descriptions should not
contradict each other
if you have a description of a
macroscopic phenomenon
that doesn't conserve energy then that's
a sort of
wrong-headed way to look at that system
but what if that microscopic system does
something quantum
then the macroscopic description fails
so then it's like not true
or it's not predictive yeah
not true i think is not quite the right
like that description let you down in
that circumstance
everything will let you down sometimes
i understand what you're saying the
things are like
functional at the perspective and scales
at which you're interested
and this goes back to kind of this more
epistemological
agent-centered view of science and like
engaging in the world that we were
talking about earlier
i guess for a very long time the way
that i viewed science as
explaining the intrinsic nature of the
physical
but really it's not doing that because
all these things are going to fail at
different
times they just have strong predictive
power
and maybe it was very wrong of me early
on to ever think
that science was describing the
intrinsic nature of the physical
i don't think it's entirely wrong you do
get something
through distilling more and going more
toward the particle and field level
in that once you specify something that
that quantum mechanics and the standard
model of particle physics say
gives you a well-defined answer to then
you feel really sure
that you're going to get that result you
do get
a dramatically higher level of
confidence from
doing that distilling process and
idealizing a system enough that you can
actually
do the mathematics to figure out what
should happen according to the
fundamental
physical laws as we describe them in
terms of particles and fields and so on
so i think that's the sense in which
they're extra true
or real or fundamental is that you get
that higher level of confidence
but at the cost that you had to shoehorn
your physical system
either add in assumptions or cut away
things in order to make it something
that is
describable using that level of
description
you know not everyone will will agree
with the way that i'm characterizing
this i think you'd talk to other
physicists
they would say yes there are
approximations but
really there's this objective
description you know there's this
fundamental description
in terms of particles and fields and
we're just making different
approximations to it when we talk about
these other levels
i don't think there's much of a
difference operationally in terms of
that way of talking about it in mind but
i
think this is a more true to life
description of reality i guess
right so i mean there are the
fundamental forces and the fundamental
forces are what evolve everything
and you're saying that the emergent
things have to do with adding and
cutting away things
so that you can like simplify the whole
process and extract out these other
rules
and laws which are still highly
predictive is that all true to say so
far
somewhat i think it's just that we we
don't actually do any of that
we very very very very rarely take a
more fundamental set of rules and derive
yeah yeah that's not how science works
right we think that there is such a
process in principle
right but not in practice but yeah
understanding in principle would
give us more information about how
reality is
i don't believe that there is in
principle that
process i think the going from the more
fundamental level to the
emerged quote unquote level can't be
done without taking
input that comes from the emerged level
like i don't think you you're gonna find
the emerged level in the fundamental
description in and of itself
without unavoidably taking information
from the emerged level
yeah to modify the not modifying but
augmenting
augmenting in the sense that you're
adding things like brownness
that you will never find as far as you
ever look
you will never find brownness in the
wave function it just isn't there
it's like you wouldn't find some kind of
chemical law or property in the wave
function
any more than you'll find here or now in
the state of the universe like they're
just not there those are things
incredibly useful things important
things like here and now are pretty
central to my description of the world
i'm not going to do much without those
but they're not in the wave function and
they're not in the boundary conditions
of the universe
and it's okay that i have to add those
there's nothing evil about doing that
like i can just accept that i have to
have some input from the reality that
i'm trying to describe in order to use
that fundamental description it's fine
like there's nothing to be worried about
there's nothing
anti-scientific about that it's just the
idea that someone's going to hand you
the wave function and you'll derive
that the cup is brown here and now is
crazy
it just doesn't work that way not in
there that's my view anyway
but the cup being brown here and now is
a consequence of the wave function
evolving an agent who then specifies
that information right
again i don't know what that would look
like here's the wave function
here's schrodinger's equation and the
hamiltonian
now tell me is the brown cup
in front of her in back of the tape
measure
it's not in there there's all color cups
and all colored tape measures
and all kinds of configurations they're
all there in the wave function to get an
answer that question you have to put in
more information which is like
which cup and where and when that's just
information you have to put in order to
get an answer the answer is not there to
begin with
and that's okay it doesn't mean that
there's something wrong with the wave
function
description of the you got the wrong
hamiltonian or the wrong
schrodinger's equation it just means
that to call that a complete description
of reality i think is just very
misleading
i understand what people intend by
saying that everything is just the wave
function
and the schrodinger equation i just
think that's not the right way to
look at it i understand what you're
saying like the question
only makes sense if say that wave
function has evolved to a point that it
has
created human beings who would specify
that information right
none of those things are in there
they're not in the primordial state
but they're born later later is no
different from the beginning thing
it's just a wave function there's really
no difference
in quality between the wave function now
and at the beginning
it's exactly the same sort of entity
there's no more and no less in it than
there was then
everything that we ascribed to being now
in the universe that wasn't there at the
beginning
are additional ingredients that we have
to specify
from our position things like
now and here and all those properties of
things
does the wave function just evolve the
initial conditions or the initial
conditions contained within the wave
function
well both in the sense that if there's
such a thing as the wave function of the
universe and that's a whole other topic
as to whether that's a
right-minded thing to say but say that
there is then
there's exactly the same information
content to that wave function at any
time
in that given the wave function at any
time and the
schrodinger equation we can say what the
wave function is at any other time
so there's nothing added or subtracted
one is just as good as the other
in that sense there's no more stuff in
the wavefunction quote-unquote now
than there was at the beginning it's
just the same
all of the sense in which there's more
in the universe now than there was
at the big bang has to do with
things that we specify in addition to
the wave function
i would say that constitute the
other levels of reality that we interact
with
their extra information that we've added
to the wave function
from our actual experience of reality
if you take a timeline of all possible
times
without pointing to any particular one
there's sort of no time information in
that system
but when i say oh look i declare that
i'm now 13.8 billion years from the big
bang
you're pointing to a particular time by
associating with my experience now
and by doing that pointing i'm creating
information right in
in just the same way that we described
it before i'm making information
by picking out a particular time that's
something new
that i've added to what was a barren
timeline before i've added now something
there's more information than there was
before by the fact of my pointing to it
and i think most of the world is of that
nature
that it is made of information created
by our pointing to it from our
particular
perspective here and now in the universe
seeing this and that and having measured
this and that and the other thing
most of the universe i contend is made
of that sort of stuff
information that comes from our pointing
to it
by seeing it not information that was
there
intrinsically in the universe which is i
think
kind of radical in a sense but i think
is just
the way reality is in that none of that
stuff is there in the wave function
at least the capacity is there for it
because the
wave function will produce us who then
specify that information
right but it produces all kinds of other
stuff it's like if i create a random
number generator
and it just generates a whole list of
random numbers
if i look at that list and find oh look
there's
one one one one one one one one that's
kind of interesting i didn't
see that before by pointing to that
you've now created
information the information wasn't there
before
so that's largely what i see the
universe as that in large
part it's low information in a sense
i'm hemming and hawing because there are
ways in which it's very high information
too but
i think most of the information that we
see about the world
is information of that type that exists
because
we very collectively as beings that have
evolved and had culture and all the
stuff that we've gone through
historically
we are pointing to it
okay so connecting this back to the
spectrum
of objectivity and subjectivity as we
were talking
for a long time about cups and as we
talked about on the last podcast about
human rights for example as being a kind
of myth
are kinds of properties which we're
interested in ascribing to all people
which people actually intrinsically lack
people are numerically distinct over
time they're like qualitatively distinct
very often there's nothing in the heart
of physics which gives us the kinds of
properties
human rights for example are supposed to
be instantiating in us
and rather it's like a functional
convention that is very useful
for producing value and so like we've
specified
this information that all human beings
share unalienable rights
but as we enter the 21st century the way
that things
are changing is that the numerical
and qualitative facts about being a
human being that have held for thousands
of years are going to begin to be
perturbed
yes you brought this up by saying so you
could
either duplicate yourself arbitrarily
whether you do that physically via scans
and like instantiating
actual molecular duplicates of yourself
you could be mind uploaded
and then you could have that duplicated
arbitrarily for hundreds of thousands of
years
your atoms would cycle out every seven
years or so and that's how you would be
numerically distinct
and qualitatively you would just change
over your whole lifetime
until you became thermodynamically very
uninteresting
and spread out and died but
now there's this duplication stuff there
is your ability to
qualitatively change yourself very
arbitrarily so like at first it will be
through bioengineering like designer
babies
and so there's all these interesting
things and lots of thought experiments
that go
along with it like what about people who
have their corpus callosum cut
you have the sense of phenomenological
self which is associated with that you
feel like you're a unitary subject of
experience
what happens to your first person
phenomenological perspective if you do
something like that
what about if you create a kind of
corpus callosum
bridge to like another person's brain
what happens to the phenomenological
software identity
science and ai and increasing
intelligence and power over the universe
will
increasingly give us these power to like
radically change and subvert
our commonly held intuitions about
identity
which are constituted about the kinds of
questions and properties which we're
interested in
and then also the phenomenological
experience which is like whether or not
you have a strong sense of self whether
or not you
are empty of a sense of self or whether
or not you feel identified with all of
consciousness
and the whole world and so there's like
spectrums and degrees and all kinds of
things around here
so as that is like an introduction to
the kind of problem that this is
so i agree with everything you said okay
but you're
you're very unhelpfully asking all the
super interesting questions uh high ones
which are all totally impossible to
solve
yeah no i i totally agree we've had this
enviable situation of one mind
equals oneself equals one brain equals
one body
that has sort of made it much easier to
accord to that
whole set of things all of which are
identified with each other
a set of rights and moral values and
things like that
which all rest on these intuitions right
that are all going to change
right property and rights and like value
and relationships and phenomenological
self
etc right so we either have a choice of
trying to maintain that identity and
remove any possibility of breaking some
of those identities
because it's really important to keep
all those things identified
or we have to understand some other way
to accord
value and rights and all those things
given that the one-to-one correspondence
can break
both of those are going to be very hard
i think as a practical matter
it's simply going to happen that those
identifications are going to get
broken sooner or later as you say
if we have a sufficient communication
bandwidth between two different brains
for example
one can easily imagine that they'll
start to have a single identity
just as the two hemispheres of our brain
are connected enough that they generally
have what feels like a single identity
even though if you cut it it seems
fairly clear that there are
in some sense two different identities
at minimum
technologically we ought to be able to
do that it seems very likely that we'll
have
machine intelligence systems whose kind
of phenomenological
awareness of the world is unclear but at
least have a
concept of self and a history
and agency and will be easily
duplicatable and they at least will have
to face the question of
what it means when they get duplicated
because that's going to happen
to them and they're going to have to
have a way of dealing with that reality
because it's going to be their everyday
reality that they can be copied
at infinite and reset and so on if their
functioning is at all like a current
digital computer
there are also going to be even bigger
gulfs than there are now
between levels of capability and
awareness
and knowledge and perhaps consciousness
we already have those and we sort of
gloss over them and i think that's a
good thing
in according people fundamental human
rights we don't give people
at least explicitly legally more rights
when they're
better educated and wealthier and so on
even if in practice they do get more
legally we don't even though that range
is pretty big but if it gets
dramatically bigger it may get harder
and harder to maintain
even that principle i find it
both kind of exciting and incredibly
daunting
because the questions are so hard to
think of
how we're going to deal with that sort
of ethical questions and
identity questions and yet we're going
to have to somehow
i don't think we can avoid them one
possibility is to decide
that we're going to attempt to never
break those sets of identities like i
sometimes think about star wars
they've got all this amazing technology
right they can flip across the universe
but then it's incredibly primitive in
others like their computers suck
and all of their ai is in robots
one robot one brain one consciousness
they're all identical and so i have this
theory of star wars the behind the
scenes there's some
vast intelligence that's maybe baked
into the midichloria or whatever
that prevents more weird complicated
things like powerful ais or
powerful software systems some overseer
that keeps everything
just nicely embodied in individual
physical agents that do stuff
so obviously that's not part of the star
wars canon but that's kind of how it
plays out
right even though there's all this high
tech they've neatly avoided all of these
annoying questions and difficult
questions by just maintaining that
one-to-one correspondence
and that is at some level an option like
that is something that we could try to
do
because we might decide that not doing
that leads to
such a big open can of worms that we
will never be able to deal with that we
better maintain that one-to-one
correspondence
my guess is that even if that was a good
idea we wouldn't be coordinated enough
or forsightful enough
to maintain that there would be
optimization pressures to do
otherwise there would it would take some
almost god-like entity to keep it from
happening
so then we have to ask where is the
theory of what to value
and how do we value individual people
where is that next going to come from
that last time at least in the west was
born out of enlightenment philosophy
and coming out of honestly i think
judeo-christian religion
it's very tied together is there
something that is going to come out of
some other
major philosophical work i'm not sure
that i see that
project happening and unfolding formally
right now
yes do you no i don't see that but i
think that there are the beginnings of
that i think that
i would propose in others and i don't
know how others would feel but
that foundation instead of enlightenment
philosophy about rights based off the
immutable
rights that beings have given their
identity class
it would be in the future like a
sufficiently advanced science of
consciousness
would just value all of the different
agents based off the understanding of
the degrees and kinds of
experience and awareness and causal
implications that it could have
in the world i would just do a kind of
consequentialism insofar as it would be
possible
then the i guess the interesting part
would be where consequentialism fails
because it's computationally intractable
you would want to invent other kinds of
things that would stand in the way but
i feel optimistic that the very very
smart things in the future could do
something like that
so i would ground it on consciousness
i mean there's so many questions just
even if you take the view
that you're trying to maximize high
quality
phenomenological experience moments or
whatever
i think there's so many things that that
leaves either problematic or unanswered
like what what about beings that
may have super high levels of awareness
and consciousness
but not positive or negative valence do
they
count or not does it mean anything
that experiences are connected through
time in some
large set of personal identity or is a
bunch of disconnected experiences
just as good as other ones there may be
a positive valence to experience that
comes out of
its aggregation over time and its
development and evolution over time that
is absent from any
individual one of those moments all of
which may be less good than a
drug trip or just eating a candy bar
but like a life of eating candy bars
versus a
less pleasurable but more fulfilling
life
how do we quantify those things against
each other and the repugnant conclusion
like what do we think about the
repugnant conclusion that's like kind of
that
the quick definition the repugnant
conclusion is how you would compare
a very small limited number of amazing
experiences
against an astronomically large number
of experiences which are just
barely better than non-existence
very very very very slightly better than
like a valence of zero
and if all of those added up to be just
like a fraction of a hair larger than
the few really really good experiences
which world should you pick
hedonic consequentialism would argue
that you should pick the astronomically
large number of experiences that are
barely worth living
and that to some is repugnant
i think it's safe to say that there is
no proposal on the table
that everyone feels like oh yeah that's
the way to do it and i'd be profoundly
suspicious of anything that
claimed to be that so i don't think
they're going to be easy answers but
it may be that there's at least a
framework from which we can stand to get
into some of the complexities and that
may be a very different framework than
the one that we have
now but where that will come from and
how
we would transition to it and what that
would mean and what kind of terrible
and wonderful consequences that might
have i think
certainly nobody knows and it's not even
clear that anybody has a sense of what
that will look like
right so i think that one of the last
questions here and perspectives that i'd
like to get from you
are how this perspective
on how human perspectives on identity
changes what we want so like this
one-to-one correspondence
one body one brain one phenomenological
self
that feels like its consciousness is its
own and is like an island
how that experience changes what human
beings want in the 21st century
with regards to upgrading or merging
with ai in technology or
with cryonics if everything and everyone
is numerically and quantitatively
completely impermanent such that no
matter what kind of technological
intervention we do in 100 to 200 years
everyone will either be
thermodynamically scattered
or like so completely and fundamentally
changed that you won't be able to
recognize yourself
and like the ethical implications of
this and like how it changes what kinds
of futures
people want i'm curious to know if you
have any
thoughts of this holding in the
perspective in your head of
max's book life 3.0 and the kinds of
world trajectories that people are
interested in
from there yeah that's a
big question that's hard to know how to
approach
i think there are many
genuinely qualitatively different
possible futures
so i don't think there is a way that
things are going to turn out
in terms of all these questions i think
it's going to be historically contingent
and there are going to be
real choices that we make you know i'm
of two minds
in this in in that i do sort of believe
in something like
moral progress and that i feel like
there's an agreed
sense that we feel now that things that
we did in the past were morally
incorrect and that we've learned new
moral truths
that allow us to live in a better way
than we used to
at the same time i sort of feel like
there are ways that society has turned
out it could have been that
the world became much more dominated by
eastern philosophy than western
philosophy
say and i think we would probably still
feel like we had made moral progress
through that somewhat different history
as we've made moral progress through
this
history that we did take i'm torn
between a feeling that there is
real moral progress that that progress
is not towards some predefined
optimal moral system that we're going to
progress towards and find
but that the progress will also have a
whole bunch of contingent
things that occur through our society's
evolution through chance or through
choice that we make
and that there genuinely are very
different paths that we have ahead of us
and no small part of that will be our
current way of thinking in our current
values and how we try to keep things
aligned with those current values
so i think there there will be a strong
desire
to maintain this sort of one-to-one
connection between
identity and moral value and mind and so
on
and that things that violate that i
think are going to be seen
as threats they are profound threats to
our
current moral system how that will play
out
is really unforeseeable will those be
seen as threats
that we eventually just say actually
they weren't that scary after all and we
just have to adjust will
they be threats that are just pushed
aside by the tide of reality and
technology
will they be threats that we decide are
so threatening that we want to hold on
and like really
solidify and codify this relation and i
think those are all possibilities
and it's also possible that i'm wrong
and that there will just be the smooth
evolution where
our connection between our phones will
become brain interfaces and we'll just
get more and more
de-individualized in some smooth way
and that people will sound an alarm that
that's happening and no one will care
and that's also quite possible whether
that alarm is appropriate or not
right yeah they just like look at the
guy sounding the alarm and then stick
the plug in their head right so
it's good for us all to think deeply
about this and
and think about what preferences we have
because where we go will end up being
some combination of where the technology
goes and what preferences we choose and
how we express them
and part of the direction will be
determined by those that
express their preferences convincingly
and loudly
and have some arguments for them and
that
defend them and so on like that's how
our progress happens
some set of ideas prevails and we can
hope that it's
that it's a good one you know i have my
own
personal prejudices and preferences
about some of the questions that are for
example asked in max's book about
what futures are most preferred
and at some point i may put more time
into developing
those into arguments and see if i still
feel those preferences or believe them
i'm not sure that i'm ready to do that
at the moment
but i think that's something that we all
have to do i mean i think i do
feel a little bit like step one was to
identify some of the thorny questions
that we're going to have to answer
and talk about how we have to have a
conversation about those things and how
difficult those questions are going to
be
but at some point we're actually going
to have to start taking positions
on some of those questions and i think
that's something that largely nobody's
doing now
but it's not clear how much time we have
before we need to have thought about
them
and actually taken a position on them
and argued it out and
had some sort of positions prevail the
alternative to that
is sort of this random process driven
by the technology and the other social
forces that are at work
like muddied interests and social
imperatives and all those sorts of
things
having these questions decided by those
forces rather than
reflection and thinking and debate among
people who are trying really hard to
think about these questions that seems
like not such a great idea
yeah i agree that's my felt sense too
okay so we went from talking to
information
about like emergence to identity and
i think it would be really helpful if
you could tie together in particular
the information discussion with how that
information perspective and discussion
can inform
these questions about identity in the
21st and 22nd centuries
yeah i guess one way that the identity
and the information parts are connected
is i made this argument that a lot of
what the world is is information that is
associated with
a particular vantage point in a
particular
set of pointings to things that we have
as
an agent as a perspective in the world
and i think that there's a question as
to whether there is
moral value in that there's a real sense
that every person views the world
from their own perspective but i think
it's more real than that in that when
you identify
a view of the world and all that comes
with that
it really is creating a world in a sense
there's some of the world that's
objective at various different levels
but a lot of what the world is is
what is created by an individual
standpoint and vantage point
that is seeing that world and
interacting with it
so i do wonder is there some sense of
grounding
some level of value on that creative act
you know on the fact that as a
individual
agent that understands and exists over
time
and assembles this whole sophisticated
complicated view of the world that has
all this information content to it
should we not accord some
high level of of normative value to that
that it's not just a way to describe how
the world is made
but what is valuable in the world be
connected with that sort of creation
process
by the individual standpoint so that may
be a
sort of a seed for developing some
bridge between the
view of reality as information
information
as something that is largely connected
with a
vantage point and a vantage point as
something that is personal self-identity
and is connected now with
individual consciousness and mind and
brain and so on
is there a way to inhere value in that
ability to create lots of sophisticated
information
through interaction with the world that
would bring value
to also not just individuals but sets of
individuals that together
create large amounts of information
that's something to develop further i
think that kind of linked
that view of how the world is
constituted is this interaction between
the agent and the world maybe there's
something there in terms of
a seed for how to ground moral value in
a way that's distinct from the
identification that we do now
i guess there's also this facet where
this process
of agents asking particular questions
and specifying certain kinds of
properties that they
care about and pointing to specific
things
that like that process is the same
process of construction
of the self or like the egocentric
phenomenal
experience and conceptual experience of
self this is all just
information that you specify as part of
this identification
process and a reification process of
self
it would be very good if everyone were
mindful enough
about thinking about where on the
spectrum of objectivity and subjectivity
these things they take to ultimately be
part of self actually fall
and like what are the questions and
properties and features they're actually
constituted of
and then what will happen is likely your
commonly held intuitions will largely be
subverted
and maybe you'll still be interested in
being a strong nationalist
but maybe you'll have a better
understanding of what it's actually
constituted of
it's the buddhist perspective i'm just
articulating it
i think through the language and
concepts that you've provided
where one begins seeing conventional
reality
as how it's actually being formulated
and no longer
confused confuses the conventional as
the ultimate
yeah there's a lot of sophistication i
think to buddhist moral thinking
but a lot of it is based around this
notion of avoiding suffering
in sentient beings and i think there are
so many different sorts of suffering and
so many different levels that just
avoiding suffering ends up implying a
lot of stuff
because we're very good at suffering
when our needs are not met
avoiding suffering is very very
complicated because our unmet needs are
very very complicated
the view that i was just pointing to is
pointing towards some level of value
that is
rather distinct from suffering because
one can imagine
a super sophisticated system that has
this incredibly rich
identity and incredibly rich view of the
world
and may suffer or not and
it's not clear how closely connected
those things are
you know it's always dangerous when you
think about how to ground value because
you realize
that any answer you have to that
question leaves certain things out
you know if we try to ground value in
sophistication of
world view or something like that then
do we really not value
young kids i mean that seems monstrous
even though they have a pretty
simple-minded world view
that seems wrong so yeah i think there
are no
easy answers to this but that's just a
sense in which i think i do
feel instinctively that there ought to
be some level of moral value accorded to
beautifully complex self-aware systems
in the world
that have created this sophisticated
universe through their
being experience and existence and
interaction with the world like that
ought to count for something
certainly it's not something we want to
just blithely destroy but exactly why we
don't want to destroy it
the deep reason i think needs to be
investigated
that seems true to me but i can't
necessarily defend why
yeah that's really good and i think an
excellent place to
wrap up concluding thoughts my ethics is
so like
sentience focused that that is an open
question and i would want to
pursue deeply why that seems
intrinsically valuable
for me just the obvious direct answer
would be because it allows or does not
allow for certain kinds of conscious
experiences which is what matters
that like that is not intrinsically
valuable but it is valuable based off of
its relationship to consciousness
obviously
but of course that's up for debate and
to be argued about
and given uncertainty about
consciousness the view which you
proposed may be
very skillful for dealing with the
uncertainty
so this is one of the most interesting
conversations for me
like you said i think it's very
neglected
there's like no one working on it
formally maybe it's just too early
i think that it seems like there's a
really big role for
popular media and communication to like
explore these issues
there are so many good thought
experiments in philosophy of personal
identity and elsewhere
that could be excellent and fun for the
public it's not just that it's
philosophy that is becoming increasingly
needed but it's also
fun and interesting philosophy yeah
and like much of it like the
teleportation machines and severing the
corpus callosum
it's perfect stuff for like black mirror
episodes and
popular science things which are
increasingly becoming interesting
but it's also like i feel existentially
very important and interesting
i think i have a pretty big fear of
death and i feel like a lot of that fear
is born of closed individualism where
you identify with your own personal
consciousness and qualitative nature
and some of your numerical nature
perhaps and there's like this great
attachment to it
and there's the question and journey of
further and always investigating this
question of identity and who am i or
what
am i and that process i think also has
like a lot of
important implications for like people's
existential anxiety
and that also feeds into and informs how
people wish to relate and deal with
these technological changes in the 21st
century
and the kinds of futures they would or
would not be excited about
so yeah i think those are generally my
feelings about this
i hope that it doesn't just come down to
what you were talking about
the socioeconomic and social forces just
determining how the whole process
unfolds
but there's actually a kind of
philosophical and moral reflection and
idealization that happens there
so we can like decide how consciousness
ever evolves
into the deep future yeah i think i
agree with a lot of
what you said i think you know we've had
this very esoteric discussion about the
nature of reality itself and all these
things that obviously like
a lot of people in the world are not
going to be that into
but at the same time i think as you said
some will and some of the questions you
know when
framed and evocative ways are super just
intrinsically interesting
but i think it's also important to
realize how large an effect
some of this pretty esoteric
philosophical thinking about the nature
of reality has had
that we had our moral system and legal
system and
governmental system were largely like
created in response to
careful philosophical thinking in long
treatises in the 17th and 18th and 19th
centuries
we need more of those now you know we we
need
brilliant works that are not just asking
these questions but actually
compellingly arguing for ways to think
about them
and putting it out there and saying this
is the way that we ought to
value things or this is the ground for
valuing this or that
this is the way that we should consider
reality and what it means for us
and we don't have to accept any one of
those views but
i fear that in the lack of daringly
trying to
deeply develop those ideas and push for
them and argue for them
that we will end up as you say just kind
of randomly meandering around to where
the social forces pushes
and if we really want a development of
real ideas on which to found
our long-term future we'd better start
really developing them and valuing them
and putting them out there and taking
them seriously
rather than thinking oh this is weird
esoteric conversation
off in the corner of philosophy academia
blah blah blah yeah devaluing it in that
way
i think is not just not useful but
really misunderstanding
how things have happened historically
those sorts of discussions in the right
way
and published and pushed in the right
ways have had huge influence on the
course of humanity so
they shouldn't be underestimated and
let's keep going and
you can write the book and we'll all
read it
yeah wonderful the last point i think is
like very useful
is what you're saying is very true in
terms of the pragmatics and illustrating
that
in particular the enlightenment three
sis had very particular views on
personal identity
the personal identity of people of color
over time has
shifted in terms of slavery the way in
which
western colonial powers conceptualized
west africans for example
was in a very particular way and like
even today
with gender issues in general that is
also
a mainstream discourse on the nature
of personal identity it's already been a
part of
the formation of society and culture and
civilization and it will only
continue to do so
yeah so with that thanks so much anthony
i appreciate it
if you found this podcast interesting or
useful
consider sharing it on social media
forums
with friends or wherever you think it
might be found valuable
we'll be back again next month with
another episode in the fli podcast